NOT EVEN CLOSE.
THEY WILL PLAY THE CHECK CZECH
REPUBLIC SATURDAY.
RACHEL: BUT IN A NEW OP OP-ED, N
OF GREATER FREEDOM BUT ENDLESS
PINGS, MASKS, BOOSTERS AND
VARIANTS, RESTRICTIONS MEANT TO
BE LIMITED, LOOKS IF THEY WILL
BE WITH AS DURATION.
DOUGLAS, SO EXPLAIN.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
THE YALE ACADEMIC SAID EARLIER
THIS YEAR THAT IT’S POSSIBLE
THAT AFTER THE CORONA ERA WE
WOULD HAVE A BOOMING DECADE AND
AS MUCH AS THE SPANISH FLU A
CENTURY AGO WAS FOLLOWED BY THE
ROARING 1920’s SO THE CORONA
ERA WILL BE FOLLOWING BY THE
1920’s.
I THINK WE ARE FOR THE BORING
2020’s FOR ENDLESS
REGURGITATIONS OF THE SAME
ARGUMENTS, FOR THE ENDLESS
RESTRICTIONS, THE ENDLESS
JUDGMENTALLISM OF PEOPLE WHO
DON’T GET ALONG WITH THE LATEST
RESTRICTION AND HAVE ACTUALLY,
THAT ALONG-SIDE SOME OF THE
ECONOMICS, THE U.S. HAS THE
HIGHEST INFLATION IT’S HAD SINCE
2008 SUGGEST TO ME THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE A VERY TRICKY
DECADE.
I WISH IT WOULD ROAR BUT I THINK
IT’S GOING TO BORE.
RACHEL: NORMALIZED BY YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO WILL BE THE NEXT
LEADER.
WE HAVE A STORY THAT WE DID ON
MEDICAL SCHOOLS AND ARE NOW
DENYING, YOU CAN’T SAY MALE OR
FEMALE.
IT’S THE STUDENTS POLICING THE
PROFESSORS AND THE PROFESSORS
HAVING TO APOLOGIZE, HOW
IMPORTANT IS IT IN THIS MOMENT
WHEN -- WHEN BIG GOVERNMENT AND
WOKE INC IS FORCING US TO PARROT
AND REPEAT AND BELIEVE ALL OF
THE LIVES THAT THERE’S NO
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN MALE OR
FEMALE, FOR EXAMPLE, ANY OF THE
LIES WE HAVE HEARD THROUGHOUT
THIS PANDEMIC.
HOW IMPORTANT IS IT FOR US TO
JUST TELL THE TRUTH?
>> OH, IT’S VITAL.
IT’S NOTHING MORE IMPORTANT.
RACHEL: I AGREE.
>> THE PIECE THAT YOU’RE
REFERRING TO REFERS TO A MEDICAL
SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA.
SAYS I’M SO SORRY THAT EARLIER
ON I SAID PREGNANT WOMEN, I
DIDN’T MEAN TO IMPLY BY THAT
THAT ONLY WOMEN CAN BECOME
PREGNANT.
I MEANT A WOMAN WHO HAS BECOME
IF YOU HAVE BEEN TO MEDICAL
SCHOOL, YOU END UP STUPIDER
AFTERWARDS THAN WHEN YOU WENT
IN.
MEN CAN BECOME PREGNANT.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF CRAZINESS.
YOU KNOW, CHINA IS EATING
AMERICA’S LUNCH ECONOMICALLY AND
AMERICA -- TOP MEDICAL SCHOOLS
ARE TELLING PEOPLE THAT MEN CAN
BECOME PREGNANT AND MUCH MORE.
SO THE CRUCIAL THING THAT WILL
GIVE THE EDGE IN AMERICA IS
TELLING THE TRUTH AS WE SEE IT
AND NOT STICKING TO LIES.
RACHEL: YEAH, IT’S THAT SIMPLE.